hi good evening I think that's gonna be
a little bit of boring after all that
talk of sex I thought I thought I was
kind of the fat last one but Kili I'm
just the English proved in all of this
I'm Sarah Wilkinson thank you so much
for coming out this evening to share and
listen to these stories and it's been a
really special night so far and I've
certainly learned a lot in in rôti
I've been specializing in trend brand
and creative direction for over 20 years
focusing mainly on Millennials and Gen Z
and Gen Y customers I've been privileged
enough to work for
forever 21 currently but before that CK
jeans Miss Selfridge ASOS calm and Nasty
Gal
so I've been around a few years I've
been around the block
I
have emigrated three times in my career
and this time obviously I'm here in LA
but
previously in my career I emigrated the
first time to New York it was 1996
so quite a while back and I moved to
starts a six-month internship in and I
was living in Hell's Kitchen and it was
a pretty grim and bleak looking
Manhattan in those days
I was paid 175 dollars a week cash which
obviously didn't go very far
especially when my favorite things were
clubbing clothes cocktails
I mainly survived on deli egg rolls with
sweet and sour sauce and drank copious
amounts of Starbucks coffee
we used to work really long hours in
those days
we didn't have computers believe it or
not
so we would have to design everything by
hand
sketched out and fax to China page by
page by page and if the if the fax
machine blew out along
which it did invariably and quite often
you would have to start again and feed
every single piece of paper three two
factories in China where with some
handwritten instruction they would have
to take the artworks together and use
those to recreate the designs
let's just say that we worked hard but
we partied even harder
we were surviving on probably around
about four hours sleep a night and I
definitely would have considered myself
as a technophobe I think I'd only had a
mobile phone for a round about a year
there was no scanners no computer no
internet no Google at that time can you
imagine and it was certainly very
challenging to build fashion trends at
that time mainly just through editorial
magazines and
pulling bought samples
if you were to fast forward 10 years and
2000 to 2006 I was working in London
holding design manager at Miss Selfridge
and I still probably would have
considered myself a technophobe I mainly
would put boards together by hand and
taking them together on large pieces of
foam core and
keeping things really quite simple and
very manual I
had a very interesting chance meeting
with a guy called Robert Brady who was
products and trading director at Asus
comm at a time I
was out in a wine bar on a Friday night
and it happened to be his birthday and
he was very tipsy and
he was extremely animated and deter
about persuading me to come and join
what was then known as as seen on screen
back then not no one has an online
fashion store Topshop H&M and Zara those
guys probably opening that online stores
maybe two years after that so there
wasn't a blueprint at all for an online
fashion store I
thought he was crazy I
thought it was impossible I didn't
understand how we were going to get
people to buy clothes from a computer
screen I mean was it even cool I mean it
kind of just looked like a catalog but
on the screen I mean how are we going to
make that into a brand how are we going
to make it into something that people
would really get excited about
I kind of laughed him off the barstool
but I did enjoy the rounds of drinks
that he was by me while he was coaxing
me to try to come and work for him
anyway four months passed and
eventually he managed to persuade me to
leave Miss Selfridge and come and join
him and to head up a
groundbreaking online fashion store
that's when the real hard work started
and I started recruiting
networking
pulling on all my contacts and starting
the entire design process from scratch
traveling maybe like 20 to 30 times a
year all over the world
researching putting trends together
it was it was kind of it was kind of
crazy times but we've started to make
headway and what broke it was really in
2008 we landed the front cover of Vogue
we got giorgio jagger in the sequence
every dress and at last we felt like
we'd made it
during that time we we launched Asus
white Asus black Asus alone Asus Africa
Asus marketplace and we collaborated
with some incredible talents Patricia
fields Marcus look for Josh cute
Michelle Rafferty Steph seasons
hundreds of people who came to our came
to our calling
we certainly spent a lot of time in the
perb
NIC Robertson CEO of ASOS said that if
the alcohol ever dried er for a sauce
then all the ideas would try it with it
but anyway we did have some good ideas
in the pub and it proved to be so
because we grew had office staff within
six years from 60 people head office to
2500 people and our sales jumped from
750 K a week to 35 million pounds a week
[Applause]
it was this media attention and
success that roused Sophia Amory soon
aka girl boss to contact me directly on
LinkedIn
she wanted me to come to LA and set up a
fashion label for her that was sis
alongside
her vintage
gatherings
Nasty Gal collection was born I moved to
LA we started to collaborate with
Courtney Love iconic original badass and
created some incredible collections and
I was there for four years until
recently I left and joined forever 21 I
have just managed to achieve my hat
trick I am on my third startup in ten
years I
have just managed to do the brand and
creative direction for a company called
Riley rose which you may not have heard
of just yet and
but we launched our first store in
Glendale Galleria last month
it is a lifestyle and beauty brand and
really is the next generation of brown
so highly integrated between the online
and offline experience and its really
created for millennial girls just like
you
so please check it out and the the
website will be launching on the 4th of
November
what can I tell you about the last 20
years
it's been a whirlwind of events and and
definitely been there's been some real
personal challenges in there as well as
professional challenges
but I want to leave you with a couple of
things that I think have helped me
through the last 20 years
I want to say to you all be brave
dream the impossible dream the
impossible is possible and
be a badass and
have a good night and Cheers I'll see
you at the bar
[Applause]